joining us here on the rich eyes and
show kind enough to repeat appear here
as he's been on the show before meta
world peace back on the rich eisen show
how you doing sir
yeah everything man how you doing i'm
doing great thanks for calling in what
do you think of what's going on right
now
meta i mean i i wonder what your your
two cents on the subject matter seeing
what fans are doing and how players are
are uh reacting or trying not to react
what do you think
yeah i mean i i mean it's a little bit
excessive but
you know at the same time i just feel
like
we have fans that you know throwing
water bottles
that's very very excessive um
definitely not acceptable don't popcorn
very very disrespectful
probably not as successful water bottles
spitting
very very disrespectful and definitely
uh not accepted running on the court
touching the backboard i mean that's
kind of funny to me
i think um but you know the water bottle
and the
spinning that's kind of a little too
much and
when you're doing when you're getting to
that point you know you definitely
probably should be mandatory that fans
receive some therapy before coming to a
playoff game but you have to
you know you got to go get a vaccine and
show a qr code with a vaccine maybe
we need proof of therapy session now
well you know i
i it is somewhat uh disturbing
the fact that you know we did see the
popcorn being thrown
we did see the spitting happening and
that's in philadelphia and new york we
hardly even discussed
the harassment verbally that
ja morant's family received in utah and
all those organizations uh meta
went ahead and and said that the person
who
who did it their their season tickets
are revoked and they've been
indefinitely suspended from any event in
the arena
and that did not work as as a deterrent
somebody showed up in boston said screw
it i'm going to throw a bottle
and somebody in washington dc said screw
it i'm going to get arrested
you know and i'm i'm i'm wondering what
you would say to the players if
something like this
is happening right now well you know for
i mean i always just
it's not really nothing the players can
do it's more about their
you know just the control of the arena
you know and that's pretty much it i i
it's a couple incidences it's not every
fan so we shouldn't be
it's not fans there's people there's
certain people
you know you if you mention fans fans is
a positive thing
you're not a fan if you're doing these
things you're just a person who's doing
bad things
right so we need to we need to stop the
narrative of the fans
the fans right now come we're in the
playoffs
you know so it's two separate type of
people
you know what i'm saying um so with that
being said i just feel like
we got to make sure we just aware and
try to protect the players from
certain type of people you don't have to
protect the players from the fans
so um when
you see players maybe feeling that they
are getting accosted that's why i asked
you what advice you might give them
uh based on your world experience meta
world peace
i mean you know i mean i did just keep i
mean
playing in detroit playing in uh boston
philly we
we was ready for all the hostile
language and we we love those hostile
environments i used to be like man you
should've heard what that guy said
you know but when you start throwing
stuff that's the issue but
i'll just encourage the players go out
there and you know have a great time
play basketball
and you know i think the nba will handle
everything else
meta world peace here on the rich eisen
show um
and you became friends i know you told
me this story before but for those who
might
have missed it you became friends with
the guy who threw the beer at you
in detroit right that actually happened
yeah i mean we're not like everyday
buddy buddy but we
we grew up a nice little relationship i
reached out
just like because i had an issue with
him personally i
didn't have an issue with nobody else
you know i'm saying so i reached out and
kind of addressed that issue
and that was it you know for the most
part and
we we actually had good conversation he
told me why he's why he did it
you know it was a bet um you know he
told me he told me the reason why
and you know so and that was that
you know i'm saying he apologized and
you know we move on
so again i'm just all right so you're
just thinking that this is
uh a passing fad that's just because
fans are
maybe forgotten how to conduct
themselves because of a pandemic
um to me it's it's i'm i'm alarmed by it
and um i'll be honest um
because it just seems to keep happening
this is now a full week
um since we saw the popcorn being tossed
coming up and it doesn't seem to be
abating it seems to be won again
one wanted playoff day almost now
yeah i think i think it'd be okay
everybody's really excited about the
playoffs and some people
are are overly excited some people are
probably just going into the
they're getting out the house now you
know imagine you being in the house for
a year which we were and you
could go to an event maybe you don't
even like basketball you just say i need
to go somewhere where i can be around
people you know
right you know so who who knows
eventually everything will open back up
and people that are not fans could just
do it go and do what they normally do
you know versus uh coming to a
basketball game
you know and like i said i don't want to
it's not the finishing
you know they shouldn't be treated like
they're that person who threw
the cup or the liquor or spit because
the fans are doing a great job
you know what i'm saying the fans are
there cheering is
that they're they're not fans they're
just you know people that's
you know doing uh unnecessary stuff and
they
and they're getting dealt with the nba
is dealing with them
meta world peace here on the rich eisen
show are you concerned about the lakers
right now
meadow um
not right now obviously a.d
you know we need him and who knows
what's happening with with his
groin uh i'll be concerned
i'm concerned a little bit about a
championship but i'm not too concerned
about
right now so you think they can get past
the sun's
minus number three for the moment and
then it's the long-term problem
is what you're thinking they have a shot
they have a shot to get past the sun
they have a shot you know uh i think we
discovered a few things
with mark and uh lebron playing
together uh we still got montreal
uh we you know we still have been
macromoles on the bench with hell of a
shooter i think
we got shooters that can surround lebron
and the post
um so i think i think we're going to be
kind of solid
but the championship i'm going to become
a little concerned about that all right
so um what's x versus x sports that
you're
founded better what's that about oh yeah
thanks for asking of course
versus exports yeah absolutely thanks
for asking of course
um exploration exports for the platform
where you
join download the app on the app store
or google play uh create a game
invite your friends to a game uh and
then
when the game is starting and put the
score after the game
x versus x sports tracks your points and
then you can get recognized for being
the best in your area if you're a
recreational player
sign up uh join the community
uh and create games uh and you wanna
what you wanna do is try to get
a lot of wins so the main the most
important thing is
when you're on the app and you're
playing a game
input the score and press save so we can
keep track of your stats and more people
that i get on the app they are
send you a message and ask you hey would
you want to play in the game
if you're an elite player is a great
opportunity to get exposure and then
join
our x-first exports leagues which we're
launching
this summer okay and i also noticed on
your twitter handle at meadow world
uh you tweeted out about um 12 hours ago
i just agreed to my first boxing match
lol this is funny
are you fighting yeah i'm doing
um i'm doing a boxing match on xbox at
sports platforms okay
but it's not going to be a boxing match
where uh i'm going to get my head
knocked off
it's going to be a nice nice one what's
a nice box
what do you mean what are you talking
about nice friendly nice and friendly
not like the ones we see uh these people
doing these days but i thought a lot of
people kept asking me hey when you're
gonna do a boxing match
people offer me a million dollars if i'm
not i'm not fighting i don't want to
fight
but um but i said you know what i'll do
something fun
in a way where i'm not going to get my
head knocked off
so i said you know i know people always
like to associate me with boxing so i
i said you know i'll just do it so we're
going to do an x versus sports um boxing
match
you know on uh in september and
so i'm training now and um you know
anybody just follow at experts exports
um if you if you're interested in it you
know messenger please tell me you're
excited so i know
if you're if you're interested in there
but i'm excited about it should be fun
who are you fighting
do you have a um there's a couple people
that we're talking to that
uh we can't disclose yet okay um
we have heard about this person will we
have heard of this person
um yeah you might have heard this person
and it's not going to be anyone
uh it's going to be a fun match it's
going to be a fun match
i'm excited about it jake paul is that
what it is ah no not jake paul did park
a fight i would never fight jake paul
because uh
jake is a boxer okay he he's a real
fighter
okay he knows how to and he's a really
good counterpuncher
so you're going to fight somebody who
doesn't know boxing and won't hurt you
is that basically who you're going to
dis
is that we just described it yeah yeah
yeah like yeah you can read mine
sure you can read mine i look forward to
hearing that
all right yeah absolutely very good all
right matt thanks for the call
appreciate it you'd be well
we'll chat again soon uh absolutely look
for my call thank you that's meadow
world peace everybody
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here